alright guys we were here with Arjun
we've got a lot to talk about I think
you are one of the realest people and
one of the people who are not afraid to
say what you think and call out the
projects that are frankly unworthy of
existing that's almost all of them how
are you I am doing well man I'm happy to
be here is a muggy day in New York City
yeah for sure alright so for those
people that don't know let's just go
through real quick your background and
then we can can jump into a whole bunch
of him stuff
sure I will kind of start with my birth
only because it's a somewhat relevant
was born in India we emigrated to the
u.s. when I was about six years old so
first generation immigrants was pushed
into the you know lawyer doctor engineer
type mold
my parents are conservative gold bugs
actually we had a rich gold culture
growing up and still do and so I grew up
went to school in Boston was trained as
an engineer and that's when I first
found Bitcoin was in 2012-2013 at sort
of the heyday of the Silk Road you know
that first run up in price that was
really exciting to watch and my politics
were already sort of aligned in that in
that direction in that sort of
libertarian anarcho-capitalists mold and
that was the first time I'd really had
exposure to a wide group of people in
that lens so you know price action dies
I sort of lost interest along with that
you know was just who's building
anything what's going on it wasn't until
a couple of years later that I you know
saw the what was happening in the
community again and started working on
and kind of focusing on Bitcoin
full-time in 2016 and and first thing
that I was exploring is the market
microstructure itself was looking at
where were people you know trading
Bitcoin what
people using the trade Bitcoin the
markets you know still are very
inefficient but was you know far more
inefficient back then exchange arbitrage
was a very big thing the spreads on the
exchanges were very wide there wasn't
really any you know there wasn't a lot
of algorithmic execution the volume was
tiny and so that was my first sort of
area of focus and so subsequently over
the next year and a half and kind of
with all the run-up in 2017 I spent a
lot of my time helping people figure out
how to navigate the microstructure and
how to actually trade you know these
markets and where there are
opportunities to make money and you know
there are all sorts of questions there
you know not only all the things that I
described but figuring out what the
right ways to custody assets and so in
that's sort of for going all together to
the question of you know what do I buy
and so work with a few large traditional
hedge funds you know helping them sort
of evangelizing Bitcoin helping them
explore the space and have since for the
last year spent most of my time
investing and trading my own money with
you know a couple of outside investors
and I'm in the process of
institutionalizing that further which is
really exciting
awesome all right we're just gonna start
off with with a bang here 20 years from
now Bitcoin where are we and not in
terms of price but can we get to a
global reserve currency can we get to it
being used kind of coexistence with with
the US dollar what do you think is
possible here sure so I think that right
now bitcoin is a global settlement layer
we're seeing that Bitcoin settles you
know right now between one and two
billion dollars a day right notional
which is in US dollars which is
substantial amount of money I think that
over the next 20 years that number is
only going to continue to go up
I think over the next 20 years we will
have figured out you know ways to make
Bitcoin viable for
small-scale payments as well which won't
be which I don't believe are going to be
on chain I think in terms of its
existence in the global financial system
I see over the next 20 years I think
it's entirely possible that you know
central banks will hold bitcoin reserves
I don't know that it can achieve any
sort of reserve status currency over the
next 20 years even in our wildest dreams
but I think it's entirely possible that
it plays a significant role especially
it has smaller developing currencies
start to collapse I think what people
often forget is that the median lifespan
of most nations state-issued currencies
isn't that long right and sort of even
you know the we look at the US dollar as
you know having longevity and the US
government being the sort of lender of
last resort but you know and the US
government in the grand scheme of things
has existed and dollars have been in
circulation for a substantial amount of
time but I think that especially with
much smaller currencies we're seeing
what happens with poor monetary policy
we're seeing it in you know Iran and
Venezuela and you know Turkey now and
you know I saw that I think you put out
the tweet earlier this week that Roger
versatile but they were seeing we're
seeing the collapse of currencies all
over the world I think that there's a
further conversation to be had about you
know whether Bitcoin does become a
global reserve asset itself where and in
this process is what a lot of the
Bitcoin maximalist of a group where I
would consider myself firmly in consider
a sort of hyper Bitcoin is Asian right
so post hyper Bitcoin ization Bitcoin is
stable enough to be a viable means of
exchange and unit of account all over
the world but I think you know well
before that there there could exist you
know sort of in in free banking type
model nation state issued currencies
that are just pegged a Bitcoin you know
similar to how we
you had the gold standard and and before
that in in the late 19th century early
20th century we had all sorts of you
know bimetallic pegs all of which
collapsed for you know for a host of
reasons but I think that the the first
step in that process will be actually
returning to a Bitcoin reserve and and
this is something that siphoning has
covered in detail on the Bitcoin
standard and I think sort of before that
we'll see we'll start to see a
substantial growth even from the volumes
it's doing today in bitcoins utility as
a global settlement layer you know where
it's already settling numbers that
annually are comparable to gold markets
absolutely ensue as this global
settlement layer becomes more prevalent
do you think that these smaller
currencies and smaller markets actually
gravitate towards it in the short term
or do you think it's something where
they'll continue to kind of flounder and
really suffer until you know some other
event makes this overly attractive to
them major if you look at big you know
turkey for example right now there's
some flight to Bitcoin but it's not you
know kind of half the economy right and
so how do you think about that yeah I
think that there's there's two ways of
thinking about it one is over a very
very long term view and the reality is
that in that very long term view so long
as it survives another day
you know Bitcoin is almost like a black
hole right it's a black hole sucking in
all assets that are you know weaker
forms of money I think that over a very
very long time horizon it's entirely
possible that this could include the US
dollar on shorter timeframes I think
it's it's most relevant to even see
what's happening in Venezuela for
example where citizens are swapping
bolivars for you know primarily dollars
but also Bitcoin because even dollars
you know despite the fact that there's
substantial number of dollars that are
printed every year are still
significantly harder form of money than
bolivars
and I think that what will happen over
time is you know
that people will always have the the
sort of inclination to you know use
their their weak forms of money and and
to acquire and hoard stronger forms of
money especially if they don't have
widespread access to it like they do
Bitcoin and so in the short term I think
that we'll start to see you know the
shift in economies where they absolutely
have to where they have no other choice
so in Venezuela even if you had bought
Bitcoin at the highest possible local
rate at the peak of the market in
December your purchasing power in you
know relative to bolivars would still be
twice you know what it would be if you
would help bolivars despite the fact
that Bitcoin has dropped by a factor of
three and and so I think that in the
short term will start to see shifts
where people have no other choice
especially in countries that have
significant capital controls where
they're still able to bring in Bitcoin
and and in the long term we'll see what
we'll have to I think that it's
inevitable that we'll see it we'll see a
convergence effect there absolutely yeah
one of the things is interesting to me
is a lot of people talk about the
currency element of Bitcoin right but
there's also a income aspect to it as
well and so earlier this week I wrote
this thing a gentleman from Venezuela
all right so he's a lawyer i Scott three
young kids and about it sounds like two
and a half three years ago he started to
feel some of the economic pressure he
started a business for spare car parts
right and so as he's going through more
and more inflation is hitting and right
about the time where he realizes you
know to to knife years into his business
hey this isn't gonna work he discovers
Bitcoin cryptocurrency etc and so he's
not you know poor he's not wealthy by
American standards but you know he had a
little bit of money and so he bought a
minor s7 and so he starts mining
cryptocurrency right bitcoins
specifically and then he bought another
machine and now his family literally
lives off of the income that they
received from a couple of these machines
and so it's you know as long as he has
electricity and he can plug that machine
and he's able to then go from Bitcoin to
fiat you know he's got an
come stream regardless of the economic
situation around them and when you do
the math I think that one of the
interesting parts is he was telling me
that the minimum wage in Venezuela today
is a dollar 25 right and kind of the US
currency
but as9 is mining you know 110 130 bucks
depending where the price and difficulty
is and so it's making him wealthy
compared to that country standards you
know in in that you know kind of
perspective how do you think people in
those countries will continue to use
cryptocurrency you know whether it's
trading mining etc as a supplement to
income not just as a store of value sure
so I I don't there the original vision
for you know 21 as I remember was
actually that they were gonna produce a
six that people were gonna have you know
all over the world it was going to be
embedded in their IOT devices on their
phones etc that everyone would sort of
you know latent ly be you know earning
Bitcoin on a continual basis and that
autonomously Alder all their devices are
going to be able to frictionlessly sort
of transact with each other and a lot of
the original visions for Bitcoin very
much imagined the world expanding in
this way where people would be mining
their own Bitcoin and that miners you
know wouldn't really be industrialized
the way that they were I think that was
a mistake that many and it not a mistake
even but just necessarily something that
early bitcoiners often didn't anticipate
they didn't see the growth of industrial
scale mining operations especially folk
concentrated in China I think that the
the way I think regular people can can
be significantly impacted with Bitcoin
is actually an extension of what's
already happening by the Internet where
you know they could live in a regime
with substantial capital controls but so
long as they have sort of unfettered
access to the Internet
either directly or via VPN there's
pretty much nothing preventing them from
earning
you know global sort of living wages so
to speak the most the best example that
I can describe here is actually there
recently I bought a wallet
I bought a wallet directly from someone
in Venezuela no not a Bitcoin long I
bought a physical wallet and the wallet
has some significance I have it in my
backpack so I'll show you but the wallet
is made out of boulevards and in the
because that's kind of reflective of how
much the currency is worth and so I you
know I bought it I wanted to support you
know this guy and his family and now the
thing that I've been talking to him
about is setting up a storefront for him
so did he Keys accept Bitcoin payments
directly ship things out directly
because he you know still has entire
freedoms to do that where they can earn
a wage entirely independent of their
financial system yep
allows him to accept Bitcoin directly
and so we've been working on trying to
figure out the best way to get them up
and running there I think that that's
what's really unlocked is is this sort
of frictionless commerce that can take
place all over the world and it's easy
to you know produce commentary and say
well you know transaction fees are 50
Cent's and it's really hard to open a
lightning channel nobody's really using
lightning Network yet and there are all
these problems but I think the reality
is that if you if you sort of look at it
bottom-up and you see what how people
are using Bitcoin on the ground and what
you know people's sort of psychosocial
perception is of it you know it's easy
to see how it's changing people's lives
already absolutely and you know I think
the incredible part is what are we ten
years in less than 10 years right let's
not and so it's a it's been pretty
impactful our you know on that global
scale what um what do you think about
Wall Street kind of you know it seems
like turning a corner a little bit and
starting to say from the previous
statement of you know not Bitcoin but
blockchain to now it sounds like
definitely blockchain and maybe Bitcoin
right it's kind of I think where we are
right now where people are saying you
know maybe there is actually some value
to to the digital currency he's got a
deflationary model etc how do you kind
of see that impacting one the currency
and then to kind of you know the future
outlook yeah absolutely
I think that Wall Street is in the
business of taking fees right Wall
Street is it's fundamentally investment
banking commercial banking etc it's it's
a middleman business it's it's a
business where you have a corporate
entity who is providing a service for
clients and taking a fee for being in
the middle of transactions fundamentally
Bitcoin is about the opposite of that
right it's it's about the ability to
trust lessly disintermediate the process
entirely and conduct frictionless
commerce with two different parties who
don't have to know each other and it's
not a surprise to me that Wall Street
has historically not been receptive to
Bitcoin why they've chose to focus on on
sort of blockchain not Bitcoin I think
that blockchain for Wall Street is
actually something that is fundamentally
nonsensical you know because it's a
close friend of mine morad often likes
to say that block chains don't create
revenues block chains destroy revenues
you know by their very nature if done
correctly they would take away revenues
from the core businesses of many banks
the sort of alternative this alternate
parallel capital market structure that
people are building is actually a
universe where traditional underwriters
and middlemen don't make any money and
you know we're starting to see the
downstream effects of this I see us this
year I have financed much and this is
nothing to save the quality of these I
SEOs which is extraordinarily poor but I
SEOs in aggregate have raised more money
globally than IPOs have in q1 and q2
this year and so I think that there is a
shift and I'm in a focus on Bitcoin but
I think that it's more driven by just
demand that they're seeing from high
high net worth clients institutional
clients about custody trading Bitcoin
about buying it holding it in their
accounts about providing prime brokerage
services around it
I think that some of the more savvy
banks are looking ahead to this but I
don't I don't think the fundamental
attitude has changed I still see a lot
of enterprise blockchain permission
block
projects not none of which have shipped
anything of value I think it's pretty
safe to say that to date and a lot of
these efforts have actually imploded but
Wall Street they there's a number of
things that they bring I think that the
capital that comes with Wall Street is
very important in order to sort of
institutionalize Bitcoin as a real asset
class
I think the second really important
thing is that with Wall Street comes a
lot better security tools custody tools
market infrastructure liquidity all of
which is good for all Bitcoin users not
just you know Wall Street I think the
third thing that's really interesting is
that with Bitcoin is going to come you
know Bitcoin on Wall Street is going to
come all sorts of interesting new
financial products some of which I've
been exploring but you know the lowest
hanging fruit is sort of ETFs and
options and other derivatives products
all of which I think helped contribute
to you know bitcoins path as a highly
liquid you know saleable good absolutely
what uh what was your first experience
with Bitcoin and like what drew you into
it I was the attraction - yeah yeah so I
my first interaction with Bitcoin was
actually transacting on the Silk Road
you know free Ross if any if anybody
listening doesn't know the Ross Ulbricht
story that's it's a great story you know
despite the fact that he was framed so
so free Ross but that was my first
exposure to Bitcoin and and first it
just seemed like a sort of gimmick fad
fake Internet token that and I didn't
even think twice about it I didn't think
about scarcity I didn't think about you
know anything else and then sort of
later that year in early in 2013 was
when I first started to look into it and
and sort of think through you know hey
what why are people interested in this
what is the appeal who works on it right
because you know admittedly and this is
kind of embarrassing the first time
I saw a Bitcoin I actually thought it
was a company I didn't realize it was
this you know sort of globally
distributed network I thought you know I
was like what's this company Bitcoin you
know who runs it well what are they
working on I can't find the website yeah
they got some wild ideas right exactly I
was like this is kind of a crazy idea I
was like I love it
and so that was that was my first
exposure wasn't until later that I
actually read the white paper I tried
running a node I bought I bought my
first Bitcoin before that it was via why
I did a Western Union transfer to Japan
actually to put to buy money on to buy
Bitcoin on mal Cox I'm still involved in
that in that class action but it seems
like we're getting paid so there's some
good things that happen and the you know
once it all sort of clicked you know how
it was you know sort of resistant to
government shutdown what the the sort of
novelty was around you know having a
digital scarce resource etcetera you
know once that clicked you know
everything kind of made sense from there
and but it took me a long time I
remember I looked at it recently I was
looked I looked back at you know find
finding it from over five years ago to
figure out what was the first thing I
ever said about Bitcoin on the Internet
and the first thing I ever said about
Bitcoin on the internet it is played
around with Bitcoin a little bit today
looks interesting but not sure the UX is
there for the mainstream and we're here
five years later and the UX is
substantially better companies like
coinbase exist now bit go ledger do you
know there are a number of great wallets
there are a whole host of exchanges
there's a lot of places where you can
spend your Bitcoin a lot of merchants
payment tools but the UX still you know
could use a lot of work and and it's
something that dozens of teams are
working on so it's awesome
absolutely let's talk about the the
retail adoption right in terms of
there's a lot of technologies in the
space that are fairly deep in the weeds
right when it comes to how does the tech
work you know what can we solve some of
the scalability issues etc and I think
that they probably are not
as much about how do you drive adoption
of that mass consumer right I think you
mentioned that there's gonna be some
financial products and things like ETFs
that could potentially help you know
open those gates to crypto what has to
happen on the UX side to make it easier
for kind of that mass consumer to not
use a retail financial product like you
know an ETF etc but still get much
easier access to buying holding and
transacting Bitcoin yeah so I I think a
lot of that UX actually does exist right
in really good ways I think quayne base
you know despite all a lot of their
foibles has done a pretty good job of
there I think Square has done an amazing
job I actually think Square has now the
best experience for using and working
with Bitcoin but I think that the a lot
of the you know when when people say we
need more user adoption or growth
they're often focused on the usability
of products that interface with you know
with cryptocurrencies and I actually
think that that's not the sort of main
bottleneck I think that the harder
problem is actually you know shifting
the narrative right it's explaining and
educating investors whether their
institutional whether their retail on
what the merits of a non-sovereign money
system could be right and I think from
their branching into and exploring you
know well what are other forms of money
that could exist besides so a crypto
money that could exist besides Bitcoin
what is the path to monetization of
something like ether etcetera but it's I
think all of that is grounded in an
education campaign more than an actual
usability exercise I think what we've
seen in the past especially in the last
retail grown up is that a lot of the
emphasis was around retail investors
trying to seize what I'll describe as
the next Bitcoin which I find is pretty
misguided effort you know but we saw
ripple run up substantially we saw you
know yes and ether run up substantially
and I think what was couched and we saw
Cardinal run up substantially especially
in Asian markets where it has very
broad-based appeal I think that all of
these users are looking for something
that is better faster cheaper has higher
transaction throughput etc than Bitcoin
right I think that that's what's driving
a lot of retail interest is because they
think that they can capture something
that is meaningful a better than Bitcoin
on those axes and I think that that
approach is actually totally misguided I
don't think it makes much sense I think
that what that reflects to me is
actually that users don't understand
the value proposition of Bitcoin right
they might be buying Bitcoin that won't
be holding Bitcoin they might even be
using Bitcoin but I think that that
education campaign is kind of the first
place to start is is teaching all
investors institutional or retail what
the value propositions of Bitcoin are
what the history behind cryptocurrencies
is and kind of where you know sort of
value can can accrue and be captured
long term absolutely and so do you think
that the people who are looking for you
know these alternative coins or kind of
you know improvements to Bitcoin how
much of it is human greed because I
think there's gonna be appreciation of
price versus they're actually being
thoughtful as to you know this is going
to be better than Bitcoin and I truly
believe that and would hold it for five
years yeah right or more yeah I think
that and this is the reason why on
Twitter I make jokes about this you know
cuz Twitter on Twitter traders and
investors are always talking about alt
season right when assault season when
all the all coins gonna come back you
know and what's that shift I think that
alt season will always come back right
even with so many of these all points
down 90 percent I think all season will
come back and the reason for that is
because crypto networks have such small
penetration into the kind of global
consciousness and human greed is so
immense that I think it will come back
and we're you know about the greed
improvement thing I actually think that
most crypto projects are driven by greed
I surely believe that the cost of
issuing new tokens has fallen pretty
dramatically it's virtually zero now
requires white paper landing page
marketing team Roadshow adviser lists
actual contract deployment so you can
you know add on another two hours for
that and you're sort of good to go right
that's what you need to raise money and
so I think that that mentality in
reality has reflected in and in a lot of
greed that we've seen from projects I
think that there are some you know
people who in the world who have made
efforts till I find the misguided
I think metallic is a great example of
this originally vitalik tried to bring
turing-complete list to Bitcoin
there's a number of reasons why the
community sort of pushed back against it
you know all of which in hindsight look
like great reasons you know and then
Vitalik went and started a separate
project you know similar things happened
with the release of Manero or sea cash I
think that other projects have some
novelty to them but for the most part
especially as you get into the long tail
of you know say lending projects right
there's five different crypto projects
that are all working on some sort of
lending token I think where you get into
that it's much more grounded in sort of
greed on the part of teams or you know
it's an existing team that's launching a
crypto project you know we're really
it's a play for non-dilutive financing
because that's what all token raises are
right you know there's no corporate
rights there's no you know Parata
liquidity rights you know there's
there's really no rights of any kind
right and so I I think a lot of that is
short-termism I think a lot of it it's
great driven there are a few sort of
brave projects out there that are
vesting tokens right which is a
innovation the us technology investor
market has come up with decades ago
there are some teams vesting tokens over
very long periods of time six or eight
years
which I find to be brave but something I
would be terrified of as a founder and
so I I do think it's mostly mostly greed
driven and over the long term I I think
it's great right it's bringing more
interest to the space and really all of
these or free research projects for
Bitcoin that's how I view it you know
whatever it is you know if it if it
works out long term it'll find a way to
get in if it's something that's
important and something people value so
you got one of my questions there's
something I want to spend some time
talking about in terms of smart
contracts zero knowledge proves all of
these kind of ancillary pieces of
technology or concepts that are you know
being explored by other cryptocurrencies
or crypto assets you think eventually
get contributed back to Bitcoin as long
as they have value and sustainability
yes and it's already happened right so
on on smart contracts the rootstock team
has been a few years exploring this and
and there's other teams exploring site
change to do similar contracts Eric
Martindale at
yeah fabric on working on fabric is
working on a potential layer I guess we
could call it layer three solution to
you know building more complex scripting
into Bitcoin and so that that's already
happening to an extent and I think the
further Bitcoin monetizes it's actually
going to be increasingly relevant
there's actually another sort of
reframing here because when I say you
know hey people are working on this
stuff to push back I often get is well
all the daps are still being built
elsewhere and the reality is that people
don't want to waste their time right
people I think largely people in the
Bitcoin sort of development universe of
you know say roughly 500 2000 people of
which there are probably 50 or 70 50 75
really regular contributors to directly
to Bitcoin and and you know besides that
contribution base there's you know
thousands of people who work or who are
building on Bitcoin or built in or
building
services that have to interface with
Bitcoin directly you know these people
don't like the waste of their time right
there's only so many of them in the
world I think that what they're focused
on building right now is the most secure
protocol that is most conservative in
its assumptions that is most safe in its
sort of method of operation and whatever
else is important you know we'll let the
market you know dictate what is
important and kind of incorporate that
downstream there are a number of on the
privacy side I think one of the things
that's been really interesting is this
sort of Bitcoin development culture
where what it actually forces is a lot
of the innovation that is that would be
on like a base layer chain to be moved
downstream and so on the on the privacy
angle a lot of the interesting things
that people are working on on privacy
they're sort of like improvements on
coin join or other mixers samurai Wallet
I find really compelling as a project
they have an Android app but haven't
released on iOS yet and so a lot of the
privacy components being moved to the
transaction layer or you know a
different layer I think is pretty
compelling in the in the short to medium
term future I am pretty happy with the
privacy projects that are out there
particularly cash and Manero both of
which use different privacy mechanisms
I've been monitoring the launch of grinn
pretty closely which will launch later
this year or early next year which is
another kind of non another anonymous
fare mind interesting privacy project
and so I think that privacy is still
something that's very important for you
know Bitcoin users and Bitcoin
developers and and the community of
original cypherpunks that a primarily
bitcoin is coalesced around I've seen
demos of different I don't want to name
names but I've seen demos of different
chain analysis tools and they or a
terrifying man I think that why well
they're terrifying because they think
the logical implication of a lot of
people focused on on chain analysis do
you know despite the fact that it is
still a little bit rudimentary there's
no
a lot of information to clean I think
that will quickly move to a future where
if bitcoin is not fungible it's not
fully fungible we're gonna have a hole
we're gonna have different types of
Bitcoin right we're gonna have clean
Bitcoin we're gonna have dirty Bitcoin
and it will trade at different rates and
I think that that's not what we want in
Bitcoin I think we want a fully
functional Bitcoin the same way you know
gold is largely fungible you know cash
it has I guess it has an identification
in the in the form of serial numbers but
you know direct transfer in cashes
directly you know it's it's directly
fungible and you know that's part of the
reason why you know drug dealers and
terrorists often use US dollars right
they use cash it's their choice of
currency yeah shout out shout out Jamie
Dimon you know he was wrong about that
and and so I actually really do worry
about a future where Bitcoin isn't fully
fungible and and do you think that
fungibility is something that Bitcoin
developers are pretty concentrated on
and it's something that's improved
substantially over time and there's a
number of proposals for different you
know everything from different signature
types to you know full scale ryoga
textures but I think any sort of
large-scale privacy would be many years
down line but in the short to medium
term there are a lot of efforts focus on
fungibility that I find compelling got
it all right so I want to walk through a
couple of different people in the
ecosystem the position that they sit in
and you tell me what uh what you think
from that perspective as to what they
should do or kind of how it impacts them
sure so the first one if you're the
President of the United States and you
see Bitcoin what do you do and do you
think it's a threat to the country to
the US dollar do you think it's
something that you should embrace kind
of you know how do you think through
that framework if you're sitting in the
Oval Office sure I I do think Bitcoin is
a threat to the US dollar but it's not
the only threat to the US dollar right
so I mean the the remin be is a threat
to the US door that we know we actually
have remin be denominated you know that
we have petrol remin beef futures
contracts now right
is very relevant and so if I were the
president you know what my consideration
would be hey you know this is a threat
and and Pierre Rashard at the Nakamoto
Institute is written about this in the
past in the future where bitcoin is a
credible threat to nation-states you
know we'll start to see more and more
speculative attacks and what are the
most what are the most likely kind of
first couple sure I think that the first
couple you know we're already starting
to see it the fringes right there in
countries with no capital controls
so take Turkey this week is a perfect
example and they're starting to get shut
off right so you know just this week
we've seen Turkish citizens get shut off
from PayPal soon they'll be shut off to
you know to other sort of internet
retailers and as their connection to the
outside world is starting to get shut
off and in Bitcoin by the way Bitcoin
trading is not yet illegal in Turkey but
I do anticipate you know either that
Bitcoin will be made illegal or that FX
will shut down
yeah or that you know or or that you
know I forget what I was gonna say but
the like I anticipate that this will
happen in in the short-term medium-term
future so you think that the first
attacks are not violent in nature
they're more politically savvy in terms
of trying to use either market forces
you know access to Internet access to
yes communication outside world yeah I I
don't think that we're gonna see sort of
like full-on nation state level disputes
over Bitcoin yet but I think that it
would be you know prudent especially
given the amount of Bitcoin like this
sort of industrial Bitcoin concentration
in Russia and China for it would be
prudent to own some Bitcoin right and
there's been there are a few people
working on this in Ghana for example
who've been you know lobbying and
working with you know the central banks
of Africa to try to get them to hold
Bitcoin exposure you know I think we're
fully at the point right now where it's
more it's more prudent to own
a little bit than to not only in any you
know and you know I would approach it
the same way if I were the president
right is to do you know two big things
one is to make sure we own some Bitcoin
and second more importantly is to be
welcoming of entrepreneurs working on
truly you know decentralized systems
because I think that what you have and
and this has been described by a number
of people but what you the universe
where the u.s. is not welcoming of
crypto entrepreneurs is one where we
effectively push away you know sort of
the potential architects of this open
financial system elsewhere and that's
not a place that we want to be at all
and I think that that could come with a
lot of negative repercussions and so I
think the first order of priority is to
be welcoming of Bitcoin and all that
kind of truly hope in networks and
technologies while also clamping down on
you know sort of in doubling down on
investor protections and protecting
retail investors from fraud etc etc but
I think that's less of a problem with
Bitcoin specifically and more of a
problem it's kind of a long tail of
crypto projects but I think that both of
those things are really important so
let's keep going with the example you're
the US president you say hey we should
wants a Bitcoin there's you know two
three mil two or three billion dollars a
day trading do you just go by you know
as much as you possibly can over a
couple of weeks and try to build a you
know twenty thirty billion dollar
position or kind of what what do you do
yeah I think that you know first I would
call the guys at the NSA and make sure
they didn't create Bitcoin if this isn't
some huge NSA ruse you know these things
so you know these things happen right
we'll find out twenty-five years from
now what the NSA knew and didn't know
but you know even you know RSA
encryption in a forum data actually come
out with it privately the the NSA did
you know four or five years before it
was in you know as it was went through
academia but you know the sort of
tongue-in-cheek that's the first thing I
would do but you know in in terms of
accumulating a position you know that I
I don't know the specifics about sort of
what disclosures would be required or
which branch of the government would
have to
or what can be done by executive order
etc but the the first focus rather than
accumulating it would probably be to
shed better regulatory clarity on the
environment because you know the
regulations that we have now are
confusing they're they're bad for
entrepreneurs you know it's confusing
because it's it's unclear
you know because bitcoin is really new
right it's it doesn't fit into sort of
existing paradigms especially doesn't
fit into sort of you know more
traditional conceptions of money
transmitter businesses and money service
businesses and it's it's unclear you
know well you know the IRS says one
thing the SEC says another it's unclear
what the status of it is the SEC is
attempted to shed some light on
decentralization and I think that that's
also largely sort of it's very up for
interpretation actually there there are
some problems there I think as well
because what they've communicated is
that there's some sort of slide for how
decentralized something is here hey you
know I don't I I think that that's very
very hard to say right it leaves a lot
of wiggle room and so I think the first
thing you know you know sort of even
more paramount to buying Bitcoin is
actually clarifying you know what the
regulatory environment is around Bitcoin
and making clear that we are supportive
of and encourage development and use of
Bitcoin but we'll see I mean it's it's
kind of at odds with you know with the
state of currency to some extent right
it makes for all sorts of you know
actually even more complex strikes
around taxation right if I'm spending
Bitcoin you know do I have to calculate
capital gains whenever I buy a cup of
coffee or you know is there a threshold
under which it won't matter these are
all you know very relevant important
questions absolutely if you're a
traditional investor right so maybe you
have some working knowledge of
cryptocurrency blockchain Bitcoin but
you're looking at your portfolio and
you're managing assets how do you think
about crypto in general given kind of
your portfolio construction
and then how do you actually start to
participate if at all into the asset
class sure and so I think that there are
a couple of interesting lenses to look
at Bitcoin right so as an as a sort of
traditional investor so one is you know
Bitcoin as a form of crisis alpha where
you know it serves a similar function
that may be gold in that sense where it
can be sort of a non correlated asset to
the rest of the market it could be a
safe haven when the rest of the markets
are in turmoil and that it's part of
having sort of responsible portfolio I
think that's one lens to look at it it's
something that people have proposed I
think it's mostly incomplete because
Bitcoin was you know it was born in the
sort of aftermath of the last financial
crisis Bitcoin itself has never gone
through a broad-based
you know sort of collapse in equity
markets
I think it's unclear how it'll perform
in that in that universe and I and I
actually don't see it performing well in
the event that we have a large sort of
risk-off type market movement you know
absent a potential sort of sovereign
debt or currency crisis I think that in
that sort of lens Bitcoin could actually
potentially shine another lens to
approach it as an institutional
investors to say hey this crypto thing
is this big bet on a new trend right a
new macro trend and the trend that a lot
of people have described is web 3.0 or
something else where I think this the
smart way you know while I personally
believe that the smartest like most you
know on a risk-adjusted basis the
smartest thing to do is just a buy
Bitcoin you know a lot of investors I
know are sort of opting to own a basket
of cryptocurrencies
which will you know sort of eventually
converge on you know the market winner
or winners depending on how you think
the the power-law dynamics will shape
out so that's another sort of option to
sort of play into it
the third is investing directly which
you know many investors have done
the custody infrastructure for holding
assets isn't quite there and I think
that will change a lot in the next six
to twelve months
the financial products that could exist
for investors aren't aren't quite there
yet
but I think that that is that's the
third sort of option is investing
directly and being very wary of putting
money into projects that seem appealing
on the basis of sort of blockchain
technology right which I consider
largely to be a scam but I think that a
lot of the original money that came from
traditional investors went into exactly
that from a lot of you know traditional
you know hedge fund managers you know
private equity investors FinTech
investors a lot of that money went into
funding private enterprise permission
block chains where you know in that sort
of 14 to 16 period when investors
thought bitcoin was dead they invested
in all of these private blockchain
projects because that was something that
they could understand I think that
that's a really dangerous place to be
you know so if I were an institutional
investor I had outside clients my you
know sort of lens would be to allocate a
very small percentage of portfolio
directly to Bitcoin and you know if that
isn't compelling would be to allocate to
a basket and there's a couple ways to
buy baskets got it into let's go down
the rabbit hole of this enterprise
blockchain or you know not Bitcoin but
blockchain I said to agree with you that
99 percent of those use cases or
applications or complete garbage right
and you know if you take a step back and
you remove all of the hype and sexiness
of the word blockchain talking about a
database right I mean that is what we're
talking about exactly and so in order
for people to get that excited about a
database there would either have to be
one some you know such a technical leap
in terms of efficiency effectiveness etc
or two there would have to be something
that that you know database allowed us
to do that we previously weren't able to
do before
yeah it's a it's a sort of enterprise
block chains or back office automation
system right it's a form of like back
it's
back office upgrade essentially and the
awesome part is Wall Street historically
doesn't put money into the back office
rate puts the bare minimum because it's
not a profit Center it's a cost center
you know why invest more in the back
office than you absolutely need to this
really is a way for back office teams to
lobby for more financing for their for
the sort of essential infrastructure
that needs to upgrade and so I don't see
a lot of value being captured there you
know because actually they're creating
hypothetically more efficient systems
you have to if there's all these sort of
improved efficiencies a lot I don't see
how it might be cutting costs but I
don't see it creating and subsequently
capturing a lot of value which is you
know the disconnect I think a lot of
people have in this ecosystem broadly
not just on Wall Street but in general
is the disconnect between value creation
and value capture III think that that
problem remains largely you know
unsolved and in many teams minds
absolutely and so if Bitcoin is the
digital currency right and maybe take
some time to play out but but we
eventually get to hey this is a true
currency that has multiple properties
that we're looking for do you think that
there is a world in the digital age of
Finance where there's digital stocks
digital bonds digital commodities kind
of all of these other applications that
aren't necessarily Enterprise blockchain
but they are digital assets they're
native to this environment but they
represent or have analogous you know
kind of properties to their non digital
peers
yes Bom I I think will tokenize the
world now the I I think that all sort of
financial instruments will eventually be
digital in some form right even even
stuff that's represented with paper now
in in the basement of the DCCC I think
it's all going to be digital it's sort
of inevitable and I you know sort of
welcome that future that'll be really
exciting I think that there will emerge
kind of new capital market structures
altogether where deals will be financed
sort of frictionlessly all over the
world you know you'll be able to move
from brokerage a to brokerage be in a
very straightforward process I think
that all that infrastructure will
eventually exist because they see you
know capital markets and capital
formation I see sort of sound money
first as the largest addressable market
and and not by you know small
differences by many orders of magnitude
and then sort of second thing I find
compelling is actually a recreation of a
capital market structure around that so
I do think that this will be somewhat
inevitable but actually the things that
are interesting to me here or less
around what a lot of you know it's sort
of more tokenized securities offering
some kind of unique financing models and
on people have proposed you know doing
under reg D offerings here in the US
what I'm interested in is actually kind
of like the more subversive stuff right
where I would consider by Nantz finance
coin right BnB finances Native exchange
token to be an example of what I would
consider a subversive you know illegal
securities offering is a stretch because
it might be illegal only the US
investors but you know they basically
raised an ICO issued a token in exchange
for that had some discounts and features
for holders of the token and then issued
a basically burn mechanism where they
Babak tokens and subsequently burned
them based on their profits every
quarter and now they're launching you
know very very very sizable crypto fund
that's investing in very high quality
early stage projects and they're
basically passing on returns from that
fund back to users right so you know
what I'm describing is an entirely a
security right it's a very sort of
unique form of security where it has
this dual utility function and security
like feature where you know the benefits
of the efforts of finance and and their
team feeds right back into the security
and many people would be appalled right
they would consider it super illegal but
what they've now created is a very broad
investor base of
you know his tens of thousands if not
hundreds of thousands of investors all
over the world all of whom have profited
substantially that Hogan is appreciated
substantially and they've been fully
transparent I think the next levels for
them is moving to a decentralized
exchange model which they've been
working on for some time
first second you know shifting to a
model where all of their cash flows are
actually directly distributed on chain
right and they can do you know once they
have a decentralized exchange going they
can even do potential buybacks and
burning functions all autonomously and
you know what happens in that universe
starts to resemble something much more
close to a dowel structure and while I
think the Dow was a disaster it was so
exciting right it was exciting for me to
follow it's still exciting to me now I
think the potential or douse is very
underappreciated and all of these days I
think will have you know equity like
characteristics right I think that that
will exist all over the world and all
sorts of different capital formation
structures and and that's really cool to
me and and so around that I do see a
whole new sort of decentralized
financial system forming whether all of
these will have separate tokens I don't
know whether but and there's a number of
questions that remains that are how
governance look in this sort of a dowel
like universe but it's cool it's
exciting absolutely
let's go back to this idea of a security
and a utility and kind of Ken something
have you know properties of both can it
transition between the two etc and so
you know in the traditional non crypto
world their shareholders that hold
equity and there is utility to sometimes
being a shareholder access to a
shareholder meeting or event that type
of stuff but but for the most part
outside of you know some kind of more
gimmicky type stuff
if you hold security it's a security and
there's not much utility to it other
than the value of the appreciation etc
in this world we're seeing kind of the
blending or that blurring of those lines
what excites you the most in terms of
you know as long as people continue to
follow rules and regulators kind of work
with them except like what do you think
it's possible there right is it the by
Nance model or is there other things
that you think could possibly be you
know this kind of blended security
utility could be used for that could be
compelling to to either investors or
holders of the token that use it in an
incentive model yeah I think that the
Mike favorite utility ayah for the most
part I hate utility tokens I think that
they have little utility I think that
there hasn't been a single utility token
a pure utility token that I've seen
designed that is thoughtfully you know
figured out how it could work at a
future high demand equilibrium stayed
but even ether yes including either but
I think that the but I think that my
favorite actual utility token example is
something like SIA I find CEA's model
pretty compelling day and the way it
works is they have two different tokens
one is an equity a traditional sort of
equity token where it has all the sort
of same class structures as equity would
have and it has a separate utility token
which is used for participating in the
network that has a lot of the qualities
that utility tokens have in their future
you know sort of high demand high
throughput state it's highly unlikely
that the utility token is ever going to
make a good investment that they've
their clear with that from day one but
what it does offer is you know exactly
what it describes right it's access it
helps access utility in their network
while the security structure actually
provides recourse for vest errs
right and they have some claim and it
aligns incentives for the team because I
think the problem with most utility
tokens is that there's a strict conflict
oftentimes that emerges between the
incentives of the team and the
incentives of their potential users and
the incentives of their potential
investors oftentimes these three things
aren't totally aligned right a universe
where
there's high velocity and utility
systems and these network tokens or
these networks actually do you see high
usage rates is actually one where users
benefit but the team or investors might
not necessarily be inside device to you
know to work on it or participate as an
investment in sort of a fixed supply
world you know oftentimes these are it's
it's problematic for users while being
more beneficial for the team or for
investors and there's all sorts of
models that people have come up with to
write at work and around this their you
know there's token bonding curves and
kind of minted burn models and people
are you know that they're trying all
sorts of things right throwing a lot of
things at the wall experimenting with
crypto economics and token ah mcc's and
you know all these sort of you know
LinkedIn buzzwords almost but the
reality is that I find the security
utility token that kind of dual token
structure that has clearly delineated
what and delineated what the incentives
are for each party and aligning all of
those in the same direction I find that
super compelling I think it's really
cool got it no I think that that's a
really interesting kind of thought
process to go through and kind of see
you know where that could even lead 20
years down the road right let me ask
this what's the one thought that you
have are the one belief you hold that a
large majority of people would disagree
with you on yeah so there's a lot of
things I mean I the I I would already
consider myself a Bitcoin maximalist
which i think is a minority position but
I think it's probably more interesting
to see you know sort of even in the
universe of Bitcoin maximalism which
often times to outsiders is this sort of
amorphous blob of a community right
where everybody is aligned and you know
sort of eat steak and you know hates
socialists and is all sort of the same
type of person and loves guns and while
I love guns and hate socialists I'm
actually vegetarian so there's a
minority position there but I think that
my the more interesting question is is
kind of
do I disagree with most even in the sort
of Bitcoin maximalism world and there's
two things so one is that I see cred
credit systems and the sort of banking
systems being built on top of Bitcoin as
being inevitable I think people will do
them and I think that they have the
potential to work for a really long time
right and so a lot of you know a lot of
the a lot of Bitcoin users enthusiasts
especially those that were here from
very early on disagree with that premise
right including most recently it's
parked up in a debate between cypher
dynamos who wrote the Bitcoin standard
and George Salkin who is an OG cyberpunk
he was in the original you know he's on
the original cyberpunk mailing list he's
with I believe the Cato Institute now
around free banking and Bitcoin and I
actually find sell guns to be very very
sympathetic towards it I think that all
these sorts of unique banking constructs
I think will merge on top of Bitcoin and
credit systems on top of Bitcoin or
inevitable and that we should kind of
welcome it I don't know if it will be
sustainable or work forever especially
because there are a number of structural
limitations to how Bitcoin is designed
and and these are good right limitations
to what you know non Bitcoin sort of
Bank actors can do but I find that
vision of Bitcoin to be not only
inevitable but you know pretty
interesting and so that's kind of one
large thing that I disagree with you
know in those sort of Bitcoin maximalist
universe the second sort of belief that
I would have that is probably
contradictory to many people in the
Bitcoin Maximus universe is that I
really do believe that in especially in
the short to medium term which I would
describe as you know even extending past
to the next ten years I think that
Bitcoin will be win or take most not
winner take all
and it will slowly increase in dominance
I think it said in a roughly 55 to 60
percent dominance right now and I
anticipate that that'll go up over time
but I see two things as as potentially
being a few things as being valuable to
the market that will sort of emerge over
time
I think privacy is sort of
systematically undervalued I think
everyone says they talk they care about
privacy but you know I don't think
that's reflected all in the relative
value of projects and teams working on
privacy relative to every everything
else especially in the utility universe
so that's one thing I think is sort of
systematically undervalued I think some
form of stable coin I don't think any of
the stable coins that exists right now
that I've launched or really robust but
I think that over the next at least over
the next five years I think a lot of
them sort of you know by design will be
you know very hard to kill right and
then they won't die for a long time so I
actually see them holding some sort of
appeal especially because I think that
the design of stable coins though a lot
of it is misguided kind of Kinsey
nonsense I think that it's that
narrative is very appealing to a lot of
people I talk to you on Wall Street who
sort of look at that and go wait you
know that kind of makes sense to me
I can see you know this sort of
algorithmic central bank model being
compelling so I think we'll see that as
well so into in terms of how to market
valves the long term I am sympathetic to
view that if Bitcoin is this sort of
black hole I think in a short term
medium term that there are a lot of
things that'll hold value because of
what the market views as structural
limitations of Bitcoin for now got it
makes sense all right before I ever
before I end each one I let the guest
ask me one question what question would
you ask me the I think that my biggest
question that I've always been so scared
about how did you come up with the virus
is oh man person to ask oh really this
is the second chance so we didn't talk
about long story short I think Twitter's
full of characters of ourselves right
and so it's the exact ways used as like
imagine if we were all just in the WWE
on Twitter and like you know there's the
hero the villain the announcer the
referee etc
and those characters all have you know
tag lines right right if you ever
watched wrestling growing up you could
probably tell me you know the Undertaker
the rock Steve Austin and all the
characters yeah and so I did not have a
grand plan when I first said it it was
more of just you say that you said I
swear so the idea that you know
blockchain Bitcoin crypto was just it
was capturing the mental energy of so
many people and it was just spreading
and no one could stop it it was this you
know viral phenomenon or more this virus
right and so I tweeted it one day like
Snow Crash a little bit yeah yeah and
and when I tweeted it I put our rocket
emoji next to it and next thing I knew
people were trying it back and tagging
me on things and it just took on a life
of its own and you know look I tend to
think that you know there are things
that take off because they have a little
bit of truth to them right and that's
kind of why we latch on to them that one
is it's kind of run its course right if
you noticed I don't really push as much
anymore cuz I think everyone's got the
idea hey there's no stopping this thing
but but I'm actually surprised at you
know how bad the crypto community is at
taking what is pretty intelligent
thoughtful many times complex ideas and
work and presenting it to an audience
that probably doesn't have the same
passion understanding etc and so this
you know taking up the complex ideas and
making them simple right and really
delivering them to a much wider audience
I think is not like compelling for
Bitcoin and crypto sake but but also it
helps right and so I think that
something like the virus is spreading is
really easy for that kind of you know
lesser in the weeds crowd to grab on to
and is that the message we want them to
walk away from crypto with no right but
at the same time if that gets them
interested in or gets them in the door
and then we can actually educate it I
think actually it can be a valuable
thing yeah this is something I've
written about in the past because I
actually think that
the most interesting sort of fundamental
quote-unquote fundamental indicator to
me you know counter-intuitively is
actually price action right and kind of
fun flows right because that's always
you know I view a lot of people for you
the crypto markets as you know startups
with stock tickers right yeah which i
think is kind of a flawed motto for a
lot of the reasons I've described and
but I think that currency markets it's
actually much more important to focus on
fun flows right what do people see as
future money right what are the
narratives that are gonna latch on to
and I've you know mentioned a lot of
narratives that I personally find
compelling what are the narratives that
you think institutional investors are
really interested in yeah so I think
that the best framework for this is they
have sleeves of capital right so they've
got equity debt real estate fixed income
etc and if they see ways to deploy
equity capital into this vertical that
is attractive to them they understand
what they're buying they have a
dedicated pool of capital for etc I look
at you know take equity so venture
capital specifically as it's like
somebody raising a VC fund saying I have
a health care focused VC fund right
you're just doing venture capital inside
of the healthcare industry yep crypto
crypto focused VC fund is just venture
capital inside of crypto blockchain
space right I think where the
institutions kind of get off the rails
or there's a disconnect is when they're
getting pitched hey you should buy
Bitcoin you should buy these digital
assets there's going to be some early
adopters for sure
right no probably right you know single
digit to the you know lower double-digit
millions of dollars checks to dip their
toe in the water etc I don't think that
the majority are ready to do that yet
right they don't understand the asset
class they don't know where the capital
comes from you know on their side and so
there's just some some hurdles that need
to kind of get jumped over before
they're ready to do that but I do think
that you know if you can start to show
them hey you know mining it's an
infrastructure investment right and
there's cash flow and you start to kind
of walk them through a couple of
different applications of the blockchain
technology but allow them to invest
without hoarding the digital assets
themselves I think that's a much easier
conversation then hey go buy Bitcoin I
would not be surprised though at the
same time if over the next 12 months
that rapidly changes yeah and I think
that you know Ison and some of these
larger names I really put them in two
buckets some are the pretenders right
and some are you know the operators
right right the pretenders are the ones
who just keep you know every day there's
a different press announcement and there
you know exploring something they're
potentially going to possibly announce a
you know a future partnership with
somebody here's like the operators are
the ones you know I think Isis in that
bucket where they're saying look we've
already built some stuff we're gonna
continue building stuff it's gonna
launch in the next you know 60 days and
and you know that type of kind of
propensity for action I think from a
large player is definitely eye-opening
to these institutions and then you know
look we've seen a couple of institutions
jump already across the ecosystem I
think that you know we probably need
another three to four months of that
continuing to happen and then it's
almost gonna flip you know very
violently and people are gonna say look
if you do not have this in your
portfolio you actually are not you know
fulfilling your duty because this could
potentially be one of the highest
performing assets in a portfolio and you
don't have any exposure yeah it's it's
like I sometimes say it's people don't
have a choice right like people people
can decide when they want to become a
Bitcoin max low they really don't have a
choice right it sort of converges on
that eventually and and people will
capitulate eventually right a lot I'm
not super worried about that absolutely
I last thing I'll leave you with is uh I
have and this is going from somebody who
you know fully believes in the digital
age Bitcoin being that digital currency
but digital stocks bonds commodities you
know all that stuff not even necessarily
convinced that it has to be on the
blockchain right it can just be digital
I think that when you really dig into
blockchain technology specifically I
would say you know over 80 90 percent of
people probably start with Bitcoin and
they have this like well-worn path for
Bitcoin to enterprise blockchain to
altcoins to you know whatever and they
end up all circling back and in about
Bitcoin yep right and so like every
single person I know has gone down some
variation of that path where you all you
the intellectual curiosity takes you
there right it's could you actually
apply this technology to you know this
application could you you know whatever
and it just takes time right it's
probably 18 24 months and people come
back around and they all just man I
could've saved myself a bunch of time I
just saw a Bitcoin believe Bitcoin and
stuck with Bitcoin I mean there's the
more you research the space the more you
look at other projects you come back to
it because there there's an elegance to
it right there's this elegance of
Immaculate Conception right it's this
elegance that game theoretically just
works right it's the security model
which is the best in the world right
it's the subservience of miners to users
consequent you know is sort of in
contrast to what a lot of people believe
that's how Bitcoin works you know it's
seeing you know the success of the user
activated soft fork initiative last year
in light of Segway 2x and Bitcoin cash
and you know users controlling Bitcoin
right what we learned last year and you
can make all the commentary that you
want about Bitcoin about its transaction
capacity about its you know - about a
number of things but what you can't
criticize is that Bitcoin is hard to
change and that users control Bitcoin
right I understand control Bitcoin
businesses still control Bitcoin very
sober doesn't control Bitcoin users
control Bitcoin and that's really
awesome and once you realize the
simplicity to that and and the path to
government's even trying to shut down
Bitcoin it all makes sense and you can't
unsee that right once you take that red
pill it's just that's it's hey over
there
we're gonna let end this thing on three
words Bitcoin is beautiful yes awesome
man thank you so much I really really
appreciate this you've you definitely
have unique perspective and in this
whole world and appreciate sharing it
with us today yeah I'll see you at a
hundred cable record again